the screenwriter said hey can I take you
to coffee and have you give me some tips
on selling my screenplay
would you say well a flood of selling is
who do you know and I would encourage
people first of all I would encourage
people to submit their screenplays to to
screenwriting competitions when you
start getting a first place or a second
or third particularly in the big ones
the agents will come after you maybe a
producer will come after you so that's
one thing to do another thing is to make
relationships it is amazing how many
people that you meet one year pay off
five years later I I just ran into
somebody here that I knew is an
executive like 2025 years ago and she
says remember when we used to have lunch
together I said oh yeah and I got a
phone call some time ago from a
vice-president at CIA the agency
she says Linda remember we knew each
other when we were both starting out if
you have any people you want to send my
way I'm open to that and so these things
many times take a long time but the
other thing to remember is that people
are not just there to be your
opportunity people are there because you
really like them and then you find over
a period of time that things start to
you know develop and you want to work
together because you enjoy and you truly
like each other and I think another
thing that's really important is to be
generous there is a tendency to see this
business as a competition rather than a
collaboration and I think changing the
way you see that becomes a real
breakthrough in this for writers as for
anybody in this business we as a speaker
these people are fabulous colleagues of
mine and when I started out as a speaker
and writing books and let I felt
competitive until one of my colleagues
said to me you know there's these
seminar Wars going on and who's the big
guru and
the god of screenwriting and he says I
think it's ridiculous like that I think
you're right I've got it we've got to
all change our attitudes and it's a joy
to be at story Expo because I'm seeing
my colleagues and I'm meeting some new
people and I say yeah I'm really glad I
got over that and I think that's what
writers need to do relate to each other
and be generous with each other
you